priyanka it's so good to see you my
friend um i have to tell you you know
when facebook
gives you all those memories from the
past you and i met
on february 2nd 2013 for the first time
and that came up a few days ago
and we were doing
[Laughter]
listen you and i both both are and well
i studied engineering too so
we're kind of you know we're both in the
math world so it's kind of cool
um but since then you're an indian so is
that our stereotype
that's true that is true and my
husband's a doctor so yeah it's very
typical
it's very typical it really is uh
since then you've grown up and you have
done so much in this world and now you
can say
i mean how does it sound when you hear
priyanka chopra jonas
the author um both things are weird
they're both new um
author yeah that's like it's bizarre
it was always a dream of mine to be able
to write it was always
excited about i was just always so
afraid of it
um but i'm i'm really happy that people
are responding so positively to the
writing
and uh it feels good you know
every time i try something creative and
sort of out of the box it's
every time anyone does something for the
first time it's kind of scary right but
it's like
um i'm just happy with the response
we're getting so far
yeah and i read the whole book and i
loved every i
did every moment of it and i could
relate to it so many different levels
and
the thing i got out of this book is you
have to take a risk
uh you have to keep going you have to
have love in your life
and just not stop and it's so true
that's who you are you just continuously
go and go and
you leave those doors open was it was
this book
kind of therapeutic for you or were you
like you said was it scary as hell
like how are you feeling about this
whole process
um in the beginning it was really scary
because just the writing process
the technical side of the writing
process was really
you know confusing for me and i didn't i
didn't know like to write a book
what's the intro the conclusion the what
what should the body have how does each
chapter like all that was hard but my
co-author nan
really helped me sort of figure all of
that out um
and there were days where i just
couldn't think of anything to write
and you know the publisher would be
emailing me saying
can i have some more pages and i'd be
like i don't have any pages to give you
um so those were hard times during
writing this book but
once i read the first the manuscript for
the first time
you know it became very emotional for me
so i think
uh the book was healing probably uh
it helped me deal with a lot of things
that i had thought about for a really
long time so
it was it was great i'm really glad i
did it um in hindsight
but i was terrified during the process
yeah and it could be terrifying the idea
of going back to those moments in your
life i mean you talk about your
experience at bollywood
um when you have to twirl and you have
to you know someone told you to change
your body to the point you were bullied
in school and
and you talked about you know how you
got picked on because of this color of
your skin and the word golly came up and
i had to stop because
that's what i dealt with too and so um
thank you for that for speaking your
truth because it helps a lot of people
um when you what would you say to young
girls who are
in that moment right now the pressure
that they're dealing with in their
career
i would just say like you said earlier
keep moving you know yeah
people circumstances environment
life all of it changes every single day
but the only thing that we can control
is not
everything around us but ourselves so
the way i've seen it and again this is
not something i knew in my 20s i really
came to understanding it only much later
but
um it's just taking one step every day
or every hour just like moving forward
so
you're not just stuck uh when you when
you have ideas or when you want to
change your life um you just have to
move towards it it'll fail or it might
not
but at least you're moving you know
yeah not to give up yeah and the the
part when you're talking about your
wedding celebrations and
i did cry because you talked about your
dad missing your dad
um i'm getting emotional just thinking
about it
um when you met nick he was the perfect
guy for you
do you see similarities between you and
and
your dad and nick oh yeah
yeah i mean they're both my biggest
cheerleaders that's
of the you know greatest similarities
i would get very excited about you know
things i do my achievements or you know
anything new that i've tried and if i'm
successful i think they both
um have the same amount of exuberance i
guess
and um also just
being like great hosts my dad and
used to always have a house full of
friends and people and
just like loved um having people around
and so does my husband they're many
similarities they're both very kind
soft-hearted
um gentle-hearted
and your mom's a powerhouse yeah
oh yeah that's right yeah and your mom
she's a powerhouse i mean
the way she supported you through all of
anything you wanted to do she was kind
of there for you
and and you've been really open about
the fact that you want a house full of
kids
which is so exciting uh what advice or
lesson did you learn from your mom that
you want to instill in yourself when you
become a mom
um you know to be able to
raise children with individuality and i
think
every parent should and that's why i
wrote so much about my upbringing
because i really think it contributed
towards me having
a sense of confidence and a sense of
self
wherever i go is because since i was a
kid
i was always um my opinion mattered
since i was four or five years old i was
encouraged to have one i was encouraged
to
you know have a voice i was encouraged
to think about the decisions i was
making not
told what decision to make you know my
mind was really
um sort of pushed
towards thinking being a thinking person
and having individual dreams and
individual desires
so that's definitely something that i
would love to
sort of imbibe as a parent if that
happens someday
one of the first things you said to me
is like uh i think i want to
i'm going to be singing i'm gonna do an
album i remember having that
conversation with you
and then you did it and what the song
was uh in my city
am i right a wicked song and
and you haven't had another album i have
to ask have you
got into the studio collaborated with
nick are you creating music are you
going into that world
at all no girl i kidding come on
he's like a musical protege i'm not
gonna expose myself for trying to sing
with
you have to you have to
music was a chapter i kind of put a pin
in
a couple of years ago i just haven't had
the time to go back there's a
lot of other things that have sort of
taken priority
and i think it's all right you know um a
big reason why my book is called
unfinished is that as well
is yeah it's okay to leave stuff behind
if it's not
you know if it's not an asset anymore if
it's not something you feel like doing
or if you don't feel like
it makes sense in your larger scheme of
things you know
it's all right you don't have to button
everything up in a neat bowl it's life
it's messy
so maybe you'll do it in the future
maybe
you're not a first to it i'm not like no
i never say no
to anything it's a it's a true belief of
mine never say never
because if you want to make god laugh
tell her your plans
so why plan like why decide that oh i'm
never going to do it because inevitably
it'll happen
that you know um that a situation will
come where you might want to do
something so
why box yourself that's true and you're
working with one of the legends out
there celine dion in a movie right now
text for you
what kind of scenes are we going to see
between her and you
well they're really fun scenes except
that i haven't shot with her yet we're
going to shoot her we have this here
um but there's some really fun scenes i
mean
she plays celine dion so and i play just
like
a normal writer and so you can imagine
what that
would be you said you're open to doing
so many different things
would you ever consider directing a film
you know i recently have been
considering it i've always wanted to
evolve creatively and
um you know i like taking the bull by
its horns
especially when i'm scared of something
and directing something i've always been
very much in awe of
um it's a really a job with
massive responsibility everyone's on set
your creative vision is your
responsibility it's something i've
always admired
on on a set um but i'm definitely
curious about doing it i'd like to look
into it
going forward at some point and with
this book the fact that you're on a book
tour right now and you've always been a
very private person
um do you have any regrets of anything
that you put in the book or
did you wish you put more in the book
no i think my book is exactly how i
wanted it to be it's
um you know the exact reflection
of what i want to share how i want to
share my terms my words
um there i wish
no you don't everything that i put in
there i'm kind of okay with
i don't know if i want to discuss it
like i don't know if i want
conversations about it like but you know
it's out there we've spoken about it
it's dusted
and that to me that's what it was
because i've been a private person i
don't know if i'm going to sit down and
be like just because i wrote about it in
the book
means let's talk about it you know this
is not an invitation to sort of have the
conversation
it's like my take on just my journey so
far
i love that i have a little quiz for you
chapter 11. it's called married life
okay i found these questions online here
we go
who falls asleep first
um usually nick but nowadays it's become
me
really yeah being married it was the
opposite
because you're tired right you're just
working so hard i mean nick is too
i don't know we're becoming each other
uh nicknames for each other i call him
babu he calls me pre
oh what's this one uh
where did you share your first kiss with
nick
um thanks for the clarification
um it was at the balcony of the
peninsula hotel
nice was it all romantic it's in the
book so i couldn't hide it
um what did you learn about each other
through isolation
everything most mostly everything
because we never really had that kind of
time
with each other um we both have crazy
you know individual careers so
we learned so much you know our tastes
our likes our dislikes
um how do we better partners to each
other what
each other needs so it was really
wonderful
nick's favorite bollywood song
um
okay
hollywood music is next like hype music
he listens to it before he goes on
shows he works out to it um
yeah he's he's really into hindi music